voy a hacer un vídeo más donde
comparamos nuevas y viejas definiciones
de lo que es una proyección ok ahora
nuestra vieja definición sobre una línea
l de un vector x es decir teníamos una
proyección una proyección sobre una
línea l de un vector xy decíamos que es
el vector en l es el vector en l en el
que cumple es decir tal que x menos esa
proyección menos el vector proyectado
sobre el de s x es ortogonal es
ortogonal a l exportó gonal
nuestra línea l y déjenme hacer un
dibujito de qué es lo que estoy diciendo
tengo aquí una línea l aunque este es
nuestra línea l y tengo por acá un
vector x déjenme hacerlo con este color
verde tengo un vector
x por aquí este es nuestro vector x y
entonces nos preguntamos por la
proyección por la proyección entonces
necesitamos un vector por aquí digamos
no se esté alguien por aquí tal que al
hacer la resta de x menos este vector
tengamos un vector que sea ortogonal a
toda la línea y sabemos que la
diferencia de vectores lo podemos
entender como un vector que apunta de
uno al otro verdad entonces estamos
pensando que a lo mejor que esté que
debe haber aquí un vector aquí debe
haber un vector que en este caso aquí ya
tendrá la punta tal que la diferencia o
podemos entender como el vector que
apunta de uno a otro
la exportó con 'la a toda esta línea
entonces aquí estamos pensando que este
es x menos la proyección de sobre el del
vector x y que éste le estamos llamando
bueno es esta diferencia la que queremos
que sea ortogonal y por lo tanto estamos
pensando que este vector de aquí este de
aquí completito este es la proyección la
proyección sobre l de nuestro vector x
muy bien entonces visto de esta forma
también podemos decir que la proyección
sobre l de x es el vector voy a seguirlo
aquí es el vector en l
en el tal que tal que x - d
es igual a w y en ese sentido estoy
pensando que w va a ser este este vector
va a ser el w verdad y si de si esto es
w entonces la proyección va a ser igual
a b en escribirlo bien ve ok es decir
que x menos b que es este vector que
apunta hacia arriba lo llamamos w y por
lo tanto w estamos pensando es más
déjenme escribirlo de esta forma si
pasamos a ver el sumando del otro lado
vamos a obtener que x va a ser igual a b
más
w cuál es la diferencia en esta
expresión o lo importante que la b la b
lo consideramos dentro de mí de mi
espacio l es decir sobre la línea y por
lo tanto w dijimos que es un vector
ortogonal a toda la línea por lo tanto
este w de aquí estamos pensando que se
encuentra en
el espacio ortogonal a la línea y esto
coincide perfectamente con la idea que
teníamos anteriormente verdad en donde
decíamos que la proyección de un vector
era simplemente tomarnos el vector
correspondiente al sub espacio que
estamos considerando verdad cuando lo
descomponemos de esta forma entonces
vamos a extender esta misma idea a algo
más general que no sea líneas y vamos a
hacer un pequeño ejemplo por ejemplo
si vamos a tomar un ejemplo en tres
dimensiones es decir vamos a suponer
ahorita que estamos en tres dimensiones
estamos en r3 y vamos a suponer no que
tenemos una línea sino que tenemos un
plano
plano más o menos que se vea de esta
forma ok por supuesto aquí lo estoy
reduciendo pero hay que entender que el
plano pues se extiende en todas las
lentas las direcciones verdad se
extiende de esta forma todas las
direcciones muy bien y vamos a pensar
también
vamos a llamarle a éste el espacio ve y
vamos a pensar en el espacio ortogonal
que en ese sentido pues tiene que ser
una línea una línea
de esta forma ok es una línea que es
ortogonal a todos los puntos en el plano
verdad y esto sí se ve por atrás y luego
sigue esta línea entonces vamos a hacer
vamos a considerar ahora un vector x en
el espacio que este es mi vector x que
se encuentra en el espacio y me pregunto
exactamente en la proyección de x sobre
nuestro espacio b estamos pensando en la
proyección de x sobre el espacio b y
bueno tenemos que pensar en la forma en
que este x se puede descomponer como una
suma de dos vectores uno que se
encuentre en el espacio
en el complemento ortogonal a b y otro
que se encuentra en b ok entonces más o
menos podríamos pensar en algo así
en este vector moradito déjenme ponerlo
con otro color
este verde
pensando en este verde y después vamos a
sumarle un vector que se encuentre en
nuestro espacio ortogonal que si le
sumamos ese vector nos debe dar x verdad
entonces este este vector que se
encuentra en el sub espacio b este de
aquí es la proyección sobre el espacio b
de nuestro vector x y este de acá arriba
es el que le llamábamos w este es el que
le llamamos w en el ejemplo anterior es
el que juega el papel de w en este
ejemplo ok entonces cuando nos
extendemos a un plano también podríamos
definir la proyección
la proyección sobre un espacio ve que
puede ser por ejemplo un plano de este
vector como el único vector el único
vector
el único vector digamos que se llame ve
en nuestro psuv espacio
en nuestro sub espacio b mayúscula tal
que x lo puedo descomponer como b w y
esta descomposición está dada de la
siguiente forma
necesitamos que w es un elemento es un
elemento único
el elemento único del complemento
ortogonal es decir debe ortogonal es
decir sabemos que esta descomposición la
podemos hacer eso lo vimos ha sellado
varios vídeos es una descomposición
donde ve se encuentra en el espacio en
el sub espacio de mayúscula y w se
encuentra en el complemento ortogonal
esta descomposición es única y por lo
tanto podemos definir muy bien que la
proyección sea este único vector b ok
entonces
esto esto todavía
promueve muy bien la idea de que la
proyección podemos pensarla como la
sombra que se genera al emitir una luz
de forma perpendicular al plano verdad
esto por supuesto es una idea que ya no
es una línea esto ya es un plano y en sí
podemos generalizar esto a todo rn es
decir si queremos generalizar lo que lo
podemos ver incluso aquí en el plano
podemos definir también la proyección
sobre nuestro sub espacio desde el
vector x ok como digamos algún vector
único algún vector único
en nuestro sub espacio ve tal qué
tal que x menos la proyección sobre
nuestro sub espacio be del vector x es
ortogonal es ortogonal
ortogonal a todo el elemento debe es la
misma idea pero ahora lo estamos viendo
en nuestro plano verdad aquí estamos
viendo que esta diferencia que es el w
debe ser ortogonal a todo el plano v muy
bien es decir estar bien estaremos
pensando que x menos la proyección sobre
nuestro sub espacio b de x se encuentra
en el complemento ortogonal y más o
menos estoy diciendo lo mismo con
distintas palabras pero es para que
quede más claro que es lo que estamos
haciendo y por lo tanto digamos ya esté
completito le llamo w y a este de aquí
le llamo b entonces lo que estoy
diciendo es que w es igual a
y si sumamos ver de ambos lados tenemos
w
+ b es igual a x muy bien entonces solo
quería darte un vídeo más para
visualizar proyecciones sobre sub
espacios distintos a lo que son las
líneas y mostrar que nuestra vieja
definición de proyección en una línea
que es como la idea que tenemos acá
arriba que es por cierto es una
transformación lineales es esencialmente
equivalente a esta a esta nueva
definición y esto es definiendo lo en
cualquier sub espacio en el próximo
vídeo les mostraré que esto de aquí que
estoy aquí para cualquier sub espacio es
en realidad una transformación lineal